Delta Airlines is learning the hard way
that virtue signaling can have
consequences
following the Parkland shooting Delta
abolished an NRA discount that had only
been used on 13 air tickets in response
though Georgia's legislature killed a 40
million dollar tax break the company had
enjoyed Georgia lieutenant governor
Casey Cagle is running for governor and
helped lead the charge to strip the tax
break he joins us tonight lieutenant
governor you said you're sick of
conservatives getting kicked around by
companies in this way well mark it's
good to be with you tonight and you're
exactly right this was in the context of
a much larger tax cut that Georgia
citizens were going to receive both
individuals but companies and
corporations of our state Delta was part
of that but because they chose to target
and be a part of the boycott that really
targeted NRA and law-abiding citizens
across our state that particular tax cut
that was specific to them which was an
exemption on their jet fuel was removed
from the legislation now I take it they
saw you know a couple of tweets or
whatever it was that said you need to
disassociate yourself from the NRA
in a sense there's something really
unpleasant going on here because as you
said these are law-abiding citizens who
are members of the NRA and yet somehow
the left is trying to saddle them with
the blame for the parklands shooting and
American companies seem to be going
along with it well I don't think
conservatives are to blame and if it's
not the Second Amendment today then it
might be the First Amendment tomorrow
and we do have to stand up and fight and
push back and do it in a very respectful
way and this was our opportunity and I
want to put it in context I mean Delta
is the largest employer in our state
they are a tremendous asset and economic
asset but on the same token we see time
and time again that companies are
wanting to weigh into the social
discussion
listen I've been a small businessman
both small and large for 32 years
and I always recognize like Warren
Buffett that I didn't let my political
views necessarily get in the way of my
shareholders and I think it's best when
companies get back to focusing on making
money and selling seats and let's not
forget with the NRA in particular Delta
negotiated a deal in selling seats no
different than hotels would negotiate
with a convention to sell out the entire
hotel and you give a discount for that
this was very targeted and obviously it
was not something that I appreciate it
and obviously expressed that very
clearly have you heard from Delta I have
Delta as I said they are a big big piece
of of our economy we have the world's
busiest airport in Atlanta
hartsfield-jackson airport Delta has a
tremendous presence there and we have
seen some late news from Delta as well
that has reaffirmed its commitment for
the Second Amendment and I think that's
very positive and I want to say listen
every family every family member has
disagreements and Delta is family's
family here in Georgia and will continue
to fight together but on issues like the
Constitution and law abiding citizens we
have to push back and that's exactly
what we did and I think it's having a
tremendous impact okay well good good
for you for doing that lieutenant
governor and we'll see how that
continues